This episode is sponsored by MagellanTV, a
documentary streaming service,
founded by filmmakers.
Journey to the Microcosmos viewers will get
a one-month free trial on MagellanTV by clicking
the link in the description.
The ciliates we’re going to talk about today
are kind of frustrating.
At this point in our journey, we’ve gotten
used to the fact that the microcosmos is an
indecipherable mess at times, filled with
organisms that look like each other, and who
have familial relationships that seem obvious
but then turn out to be a figment of our own
limited imaginations.
And these ciliates are yet another entry in
the long-standing saga of ever-changing taxonomies
that define our understanding of microbial
species.
The plot twist is inevitable.
We are going to be showing you these ciliates
and talking about them like they are related,
only to reveal at the end that they are not
nearly as closely related as microbiologists
once thought.
But we still need to talk about these ciliates
because, they are inescapable.
They are always around, showing up in so many
of our samples.
And we also need to talk about these ciliates
because no matter how frustrating they are,
they’re also a ton of fun to watch.
These are a subclass of ciliates called hypotrichs.
You might recognize that name because it’s
shown up as a label on our channel before.
And perhaps you’ve wondered what exactly
that means.
“Hypotrich” sounds very cool, but it’s
not really a super helpful label if you don’t
know what a hypotrich actually is.
And that is why we’re here today.
But just so you know, it’s not a very specific
label.
It does not tell us a whole lot about what
species of organism we’re looking at.
But sometimes, it’s the best we can do.
After all, there are countless species of
microbes in the world, many of which have
names buried in books and papers we haven’t
come across yet, and many others of which
literally don't have names yet.
So for James, our master of microscopes, and—it
should be said—a connoisseur of ciliates,
labeling microbes sometimes becomes a matter
of figuring out just how specific he can get.
Sometimes, the best he can do is something
broad, calling it something like “ciliate.”
But sometimes there are details that help
him narrow in a little closer.
And hypotrichs have some pretty helpful details.
For one, they usually have a big mouth and
a flat body.
Some even have interesting pigments, like
the gold dotting this frantically spiraling individual.
Or this pink-tinted one.
Now we’re not sure what those pigments are or
what purpose they serve, though based on what
we’ve seen in other organisms, they could
be a way to block harmful UV light from the sun.
But things like a flat body or big mouth or
pigments are not enough.
What really sets hypotrichs apart from other
ciliates is their thick hair.
Ciliates are hairy single-celled creatures,
surrounded by thin fibrous organelles called cilia.
And the arrangement of these cilia do so much
to shape the way these organisms live, from
the way the organisms move around the microcosmos
to the food the cilia draw in towards the
organism’s mouth.
But even among ciliates, hypotrichs stand
out for how they use their cilia.
They are not content to just have the thin
structures their compatriots do.
No, hypotrichs take these individual cilia
and bundle them together into something bigger
called a cirri, like a rope made of smaller
strands.
In some species, they may even have more than
100 cilia fused together in their cirri.
And it’s thanks to these cirri that hypotrichs
do something unusual for single-celled organisms.
They walk.
You can really see it with this Aspidisca,
which looks like it’s crawling across the
screen like a little cartoon bug.
So the cirri help us know that we are looking
at a hypotrich ciliate.
But to narrow down the genus or species, we
need to be able to see all of the cirri
so we can make out the patterns they form
along the hypotrich’s body.
And it can be tough to see all of those cirri,
which is often why we cannot identify our hypotrichs.
But there are some genuses that make it easier
on us.
For example, this stichotrich has a really
distinct look to it thanks to its shape and
the spiral of cirri traveling down it.
And then there’s this diophrys, which has…well,
it has a hairy butt.
And that makes it pretty easy to identify.
It’s also very fast, we actually had to
record this in slow motion to be able to show
it to you.
But this is also where things get confusing
and complicated.
It’s where that plot twist comes in, the
one we told you about in the beginning so
it’s not really a plot twist anymore.
It’s like watching The Empire Strikes Back
for the fiftieth time when you know what’s
coming, though I guess in this version, family
bonds are getting broken instead of revealed.
Because we’re talking about all of these
organisms like they’re hypotrichs, except
that it’s not clear whether that’s actually
what they are.
And when we’ve been diving into the literature,
the classifications get kind of confusing.
What makes us feel a little better about ourselves
is that it seems like the biologists find
it a bit unfathomable as well.
The 1979 edition of The Ciliated Protozoa
described the taxonomy of hypotrichs as “aggravating.”
It's good when scientists just tell it like it is.
Decades later, in 2021, a paper described
them as “one of the most confused groups
in terms of their systematics,” .
It turns out that what defines an organism
as a hypotrich or even a particular subclass
of hypotrich depends so much on what you
are reading.
One of the more recent works dedicated to
bringing more order to ciliate classification
found that there were at least ten different
taxonomic systems devised
around categorizing hypotrichs.
And that’s how you get a story like the
tale of the Euplotes.
These ciliates were first described in 1733,
and about 100 years later, the German microbiologist
Christian Ehrenberg created the genus Euplotes
around them.
And they would end up being lumped in with
many of the other hypotrichs as their own
subclass, becoming one of the old guards of
the hypotrichs.
Except, eventually, for taxonomic reasons,
the Euplotes eventually became their own thing,
separate from the hypotrichs but still related.
The hypotrichs and euplotes simply became
relatives, grouped together under a different
family name: the spirotrichs.
And on the one hand, this is the kind of thing
that makes hypotrichs—and I guess, spirotrichs as well—
so frustrating to talk about.
But it’s also something very cool.
It’s like the microcosmos is a library that is
constantly acquiring new books.
And the more we read those books and add new
ones to our shelves, the more we find ourselves
needing to rearrange them so their location
and neighbors reflect all that we have discovered.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to MagellanTV for sponsoring
this episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
If you’re looking for some more microscopic
content, make sure to check out MagellanTV’s
“Life On Us: A Microscopic Safari” where
they explore the creatures that live, compete,
feed, on breed on the surface or in the depths
of our body.
MagellanTV is a documentary streaming service,
founded by filmmakers.
And it has some of the most in-depth Science
content available anywhere: covering space,
technology, nature, and more
15 to 20 hours of new content is added each
week with a growing collection of 4K, high-definition
content for no additional cost, so you’ll
never run out of something to watch, AND there
are no ads.
MagellanTV can be watched anytime, anywhere,
on your television, laptop, or mobile device
because it’s compatible with Roku, AmazonFireTV,
AppleTV, Google Play, and iOS
Click on the link in the description to get your
first full month of MagellanTV for free.
The folks on your screen right now, they are
the least frustrating thing in this video,
I can tell you that.
They are our Patreon patrons and they want
it to be possible for us to continue banging
our heads against books trying to figure out
the relationships between hypotrichs.
We'll figure it out someday.
But anyway, thank you so much to all of our
Patreon patrons, if you would like to join
them and be on of the reasons why we can make
this show at all, that's Patreon.com/JourneyToMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.